allrightniceinroNo
pleasekillmekillme
Please
no
knowreallythathadto
liveThroughall
that
Oh, okay, okay,
Ayoshizaki, it's okay, okay.  It
was just a difference. I
never expected it to be shown at the scene of the murder. Right now,
I'm tied up for some reason, and
I'm the one who says that the child isn't at fault. Mr.
Suzumoto has a photo of his face and his name in an old newspaper article.  The
girl who was listed in the magazine, Sakiko,
looks like a victim,
but I do
n't think it would be possible for her to
pick up a child her age and lock her up.She's a
monster, and she
can understand as easily as a child.
I don't know why
he was cooperating with Yosako, but
he was trembling in the corner of the room while these children were being killed.
Seriously, I don't know why he was cooperating.  I
wasn't in Ninella.If I do
n't let everyone know soon, I'll be
killed before I know the truth.If I recklessly
come into contact with Sachiko, it'll be dangerous.I have to
go back, Yuki-chan, please take me
to that place again, and you too.  I will make sure that all the other
children attain Buddhahood as well.That's why I recommend it to you.Now, due
to the efforts of you and other people, that
space is starting to become greatly disturbed.If I
go back next time,
you guys will still have reason left.  I don't want to bring you back here again,
but if you leave it like this, let's go and
help everyone.
I understand, because even I do
n't want to lose you when you're one of the few.
[Music]
Miki, I'm sorry.
This is really what Sa-san needs right now.
[Music]
If that's the case, you should give it to her. There's a
girl around her right now, and
there's also another red statue, so if you
find that, give it to her.  Please give it to me. I understand. The
three of us who got our bodies back
are ready. Because of that, the balance of the multiple space has been
broken. Please be
careful. We
need to bring out what's left of the culprit.  I have no choice but to purify that girl.My
heart began to be violated.The next time I
saw me, I felt like running away and
looked for the girls and Yui-sensei.However, I
couldn't see anyone other than Sensei and Morishige Suzumoto.  I think I saw every corner of the school building,
but I'm sure he's the only one who's really there.
That's what the human ball I saw when I was with Yui-sensei in the multi-space classroom
said that
everyone I didn't meet was probably blown away.  We were in a different dimension.
Now, even though we were in the same school building, we couldn't meet. I didn't understand. Wait, now,
how are we going to tell them about the culprit? There's a
broken space in another
dimension, to those who don't love us.  Maybe the way they interact with each other has
changed. Let's look again.
Look at the teacher.
If there are children, then who is this being that calls so many humans into this space and
traps them?
Whyplace
BreakDownwhenallthe
otherstudents
cameIhasbeen
and
Yu?  Let's hide it here, don't
do it.
[Music]
HiSolong
P
some
that
[Music] It's
gone [
Music] [
Music]
Get out
[Music]
No
I Oizaki
What's that? There's
a lot of blood in my ass.  It's on me. Did I
get hurt by a sharp tree or something? It's
okay, just say it's fine.
Yeah, that guy doesn't
have any money. It's disgusting. What should I do? I don't have a cover, so I
don't have anything to do, and in this condition, I don't have anything to do with Ta-kun and everyone.
Enough,
Something
has fallen. Is that someone near the students at Kigi Gakuen? Who is that? There's
no doubt that Nakajima-san's Dasachiko-san's scraps were in there too. Ooh, what's going on with
Jisoo?
Shinozaki?
Whose student book is that? Mr. Nakajima is
near Mr. Shima's house. Nakajima,
Nakajima. Can't you hear him? I'm
sure he's nearby,
brother. [Music]  Stop pushing me and blowing out hot air
[Music]
[Music] [Music] [
Music]
ENG
[Music]
Mom and brother, hey, come
on, you're leaving the door to your room open again.
My head is
throbbing. It's pitch
black. What's going on? I'm so
confident. There's
something soft underneath.  I'm
young, but it looks like it's going to be tough. Thank you for your
efforts. It looks like the
blood has stopped.
Yes, great, great, what is this? Where is this? It's calm here. Stay
calm and hold on.
What I see here is,
yes, success.  I'll definitely
get this, I'll turn the world's occult genre upside down with this video.Okay, let's
start the third part of the real evil right away.I can use the raw words that I'm experiencing with my skin right now.Okay,
this is what this school building is all about.  It's a video. It's the
tape that Satoshi put in earlier.
Ah, the camera must not have been turned on,
but I wonder if the owner of this tape filmed it. It's
amazing. There's graffiti all over it. Wow, I'm
really paying attention.  There is still little data about this school, so I don't know what will make her
angry, so it's
better not to mention it too much.What should I do if she doesn't take away such a nice house?
SW: That's
amazing,
but the teacher is fine.She'll get
angry if I leave her behind.  It seems like he was left alone.
Now I can't put him in danger because he has different feelings.
Of course he is. Is it
real?
Corpse.
Mr. Corpse. That's scary. This kid's uniform
is new. It's ours.  I'm a child of the times.
Some of these people who have gone missing all over the country are talking about it
here. What a
place they've come to. Please tell me
more,
Hayasaka. I wish I hadn't told you.  I
can hear the voice
of a child. Is it true? Hey, hey,
what can I hear? Calm down, okay? I can't hear the child's voice.
Wait, wait, you're okay. I'm sorry. I
stepped
on something. Is the camera okay?
Never
HALLO
Oh. I wonder what it is.
Sakauchi said it was the way to go home.
Maybe the feeling will continue. Find Yuka-chan.  Let's
look for the tape,
too. Nayoshi, let's find a way to leave. I
can't keep up with this camera on TV.
Tap THE
[Music]
NEXT. So-and-so's demeanor has changed. As expected from earlier, it
wasn't just confidence.
That's
right, the space is sticking together in a weird way again. Anyway, let's
move carefully. No,
Sato. Wait a minute. There's
wood chips stuck in my back clothes. Ah, there's
no island. After all, it's
empty after all. What should
I do, too?  That's what I thought.Okay, that's a bit of a
joke.Mr.
Suzumoto must be
joking.Damn, you were laughing just a moment ago.Everyone, why is that?
Anyway, don't let anyone die anymore.This is my
order as the chairman, yo-sensei
and you.  I'm going to find Toyu-chan and
go home from here,
so of course I'll be careful if there's going to be a lot of murders.
According to Nena-san and Yu-chan,
if the killing squad can pull out what's left of the child, the murdered
person
will be killed.
How can I make this happen to someone who might
be able to return to their own world
? You guys were talking about the Sakauchi method you were talking about earlier, as if you were using
this tape to get back home.  I was just
saying that I was going to change the tape, and that's it. It's
like a tape, but if you know
how to do it, you wo
n't have to deal with spirits any more, and it
seems easier than the ordinance,
though.  That won't solve the fundamental problem.The
reason why someone other than Sakauchi taught me this is because they want to
stop the spread of this terrible curse.If we leave our
school as it is, it will continue
forever.  So many children are trapped here and
dying without a trace.
What can we, mere high school students, do? The
person who makes us regret it
somehow tries to find out why he decided from the beginning that it was impossible.  I
mean, it's just me, so I don't think it's too annoying.
But do your best. We're going to explore the Saka region and
find Yuka and everyone else. Yoshiki and
Shinozaki, look for Yui and the others. When
you're all together, come back here.
I'll do it.The spirit of the child who sided with me
entrusted it to you guys.Well
then, committee
member, please be careful, Mr. Nakajima.Don't
get too close to Mr. Den.Oh,
hey, what's going on? Just
be a little stronger, Nakajima.  's student
Sachiko Saki's cut will be
fine as long as you have to give it to me later.NoGiveItBackDIE If you give
priority to Dohaveit's history and
abuse your classmates,
you will be disqualified as a poor leader.As an individual, Ayumu Shinozaki has an
honest reaction.  I think I
would say
that even if I were in your position. Yes, I feel more
at ease. Thank you,
Pefu. You
idiot, I
can't even think of letting you meet Imako. I'm looking for a teacher.
[Applause]
[Music]  It's
okay over there, too. If
we go
in together, things
will work out.
[Music]
Not
EP If it's just the two of us, regret will come over me again. I
don't even know what the other person's feelings are, and
Seiko's last words are...  I can't get it out of my ear It's
okay, it's
not your fault Satoshi who cheered me up said that
but ha [
music]
suicide this music [
haveHELLYeah motherfuckersGFind
and
G  No matter
how many times I
put it on you, it doesn't
seem like it.
That
[music] is a
lie. I'm sure it's a lie. It's like that
every morning.
What happened here? It
hurts.
Where did my shoes go?  Chattan
[Music]
I guess
[Music] Sakisuke
Tereo I want to do something cute and naughty Listen to
what I'm saying
Well, big sister, you're scary,
but somehow I feel like you're not scary
[Laughs]
Who are you talking to,
girl?  I'll
kill you
[laughter]
[music]
okay all
this stuff
[music]
genk
[music] [
laughing]
JESUSohmy
[music]
godJesus
Christ
ohmy
god
WhatG
Girlbit
girl
bitchBit
Bom
[ __ ]
Girl
[music]
Find
Oh
GODlikeenjoy
watchingImakes
edgar
[ __ ]
MsomLAVImaha